RUSH'S LIFE, TALENT ON LOAN FROM
GOD.
BUT FIRST, THE COLONIAL PIPELINE
IS BACK ONLINE BUT AMERICA HAS
BEEN EXPOSED IN A MASSIVE WAY.
THIS PIPELINE SYSTEM WAS
HIJACKED BY RUSSIAN CRIMINALS
SHUTTING OFF FUEL TO THE ENTIRE
EAST COAST OF THE UNITED STATES.
GAS PRICES WHICH WERE ALREADY ON
THE RISE SPIKED EVEN FURTHER.
THOUSANDS OF STATIONS STILL OUT
OF GAS AS WE SPEAK, AND THINGS
LIKELY, WE ARE TOLD, WILL NOT BE
BACK TO NORMAL UNTIL SOMETIME
AROUND MEMORIAL DAY.
THAT'S A COUPLE OF WEEKS FROM
NOW.
TONIGHT, WE ARE LEARNING
COLONIAL, GET THIS, PAID A
$5 MILLION RANSOM IN THEIR
DESPERATE ATTEMPT TO GET THEIR
SYSTEM BACK ONLINE.
JOE, WHERE WAS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THIS?
WHY WAS COLONIAL LEFT TO FEND
FOR ITSELF AGAINST
INTERNATIONAL ROUGH RUSSIAN
CRIMINALS, OR DID YOUR ADMINISTN
ACTUALLY APPROVE THE RANSOM
PAYMENT TO RUSSIAN CRIMINALS?
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, RANSOM
PAYMENTS, AND IN CASE YOU DIDN'T
KNOW, THAT INCENTIVIZES FUTURE
ATTACKS.
WHY NOT DO IT AGAIN?
CLEARLY WORKED THE FIRST TIME.
AND BY THE WAY, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO ABOUT RUSSIA, JOE?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT
YOUR FRIEND VLADIMIR PUTIN?
HAVE YOU CALLED VLADIMIR?
HAVE YOU ASKED ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER TO CALL HIS RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH FRIENDS THAT PAID HIS
COMPANY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
NO EXPERIENCE?
OR MAYBE YOU ARE JUST TOO TIRED,
JOE.
BUT HERE IS YOUR NIGHTLY
REMINDER.
JOE, YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO RESPOND
HERE, JOE.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
NOW, TRUE TO FORM, TODAY, THE
COGNITIVE MESS THAT IS
JOE BIDEN, DIDN'T SEEM TO KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND AS FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
CARRIED OUT THIS ATTACK, THE FBI
HAS RELEASED DETAILS ON THE
ATTACK, SO OTHERS CAN STATE
STEPS TO PREVENT FROM BEING
VICTIMIZED LIKE A COLONIAL HAS
BEEN.
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT WAS INVOLVED IN THIS
ATTACK, BUT WE DO HAVE STRONG
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THE
CRIMINALS WHO DID THE ATTACK ARE
LIVING IN RUSSIA.
THAT IS WHERE IT CAME FROM.
FROM RUSSIA.
WE HAVE BEEN IN DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH MOSCOW ABOUT
THE IMPERATIVE FOR RESPONSIBLE
COUNTRIES TO TAKE DECISIVE
ACTION AGAINST THESE RANSOMWARE
NETWORKS.
>> Sean: CAN WE GET THE
5 MILLION BACK IN RANSOM?
NO CLARITY, NO STRENGTH, NO
LEADERSHIP WHATSOEVER.
THAT MEANS AMERICA'S ENEMIES,
THEY SEE ALL OF THIS HAPPENING
AND UNFOLDING, AND THEY ALSO SEE
HOW WEAK JOE BIDEN IS, AND NOW,
WE ARE LIVING THE JIMMY CARTER
NIGHTMARE ALL OVER AGAIN.
FRANKLY, ON STEROIDS.
INFLATION, LOOK AT THIS COME UP
A WHOPPING 4.2% IN APRIL.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST NUMBER IN 12
YEARS.
THAT MEANS EVERY SINGLE CONSUMER
GOOD YOU BY AT THE
GROCERY STORE, AT YOUR
DRUGSTORE, LOWE'S, HOME DEPOT,
IT'S GOING TO COST YOU MORE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
MASSIVE GAS SHORTAGES UP AND
DOWN THE EAST COAST.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
HALF OF ALL GAS STATIONS,
VIRGINIA, GEORGIA,
SOUTH CAROLINA ARE OUT.
70% OF STATIONS RAN OUT OF FUEL
IN NORTH CAROLINA.
EVEN MORE, 73% IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
GOOD THING WINTER IS OVER
BECAUSE JOE WOULD BE TELLING YOU
TO TURN DOWN THE THERMOSTAT AND
PUT ON YOUR SWEATER TO CONSERVE
FUEL.
JUST LIKE JIMMY CARTER DID.
NOW, WHEN AMERICA'S ENEMIES ARE
WALKING ALL OVER US, WHEN THEY
CAN SEE A WEAK, FRAIL,
COGNITIVELY STRUGGLING
PRESIDENT, AND WHEN THEY KNOW
HIS FLEDGLING ADMINISTRATION IS
READY, WILLING TO APPEASE
WHEREVER, WHENEVER POSSIBLE,
THEY WILL AND THEY ARE ALREADY
TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE.
JOE FOOLISHLY ALREADY
REINSTATED, WHAT, HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN AID TO
THE PALESTINIANS, 40 DAYS AGO,
LIKELY BEING FUNNELED TO HAMAS
IN THESE ATTACKS AGAINST OUR
ALLY, ISRAEL.
THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO EASE
SANCTIONS AGAINST THE WORLD'S
BIGGEST STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR,
IRAN.
THEY ARE THE ONE SUPPLYING THE
ROCKETS NOW BEING USED TO STRIKE
ISRAEL AND COMMIT ACTS OF TERROR
NATIONWIDE, WORLDWIDE, RATHER,
AND THANKS TO JOE'S WAR ON
AMERICAN OIL AND GAS, WELL, WE
ARE NOW BUYING MORE FUEL FROM
COME OF ALL PLACES, RUSSIA.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
ALONG WITH IRAN AND CHINA,
SUPPLYING WEAPONS TO YEMEN FOR
THE PROXY WHERE THEY'RE FIGHTING
IN THE MIDDLE EAST THERE.
JOE WAS WEAK, FECKLESS POLICIES
ARE SO TERRIBLE THAT NOW 44
SENATORS HAVE WRITTEN A LETTER
TO JOE.
HEY, JOEY, THEY ARE BEGGING HIM
NOT TO LIFT SANCTIONS ON IRAN,
AS THE MULLAHS ARE FUNDING AND
SUPPLYING THE ONGOING HAMAS
TERROR ATTACK TO OUR FRIENDS IN
ISRAEL.
WHY ON EARTH WOULD YOU GIVE A
DIME, A PENNY TO A COUNTRY THAT
IS ACTIVELY TRYING TO DESTROY
YOUR GREATEST ALLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST?
THE NUMBER ONE STATE SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM WORLDWIDE.
YOU KNOW, DEATH TO ISRAEL, DEATH
TO AMERICA, BURNING ISRAELI
FLAGS, AMERICAN FLAGS, IT'S NOT
JUST A MEANINGLESS CHANCE.
IT IS BACKED UP BY CONSTANT
TERRORIST ACTIONS, WEAPONS
TRAINING, COULD YOU IMAGINE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF IRAN EVER
DEVELOPS NUCLEAR CAPABILITY?
THAT CANNOT HAPPEN.
THAT COULD END IN A MODERN-DAY
HOLOCAUST, AND YOU MARRY RADICAL
FANATICISM OF THE MULLAHS IN
IRAN WITH WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION, THAT IS A DANGER
TOO EERIE TO THINK ABOUT, TOO
CHILLING TO THINK ABOUT.
ACCORDING TO THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST BASE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, OH, THEY ARE
STANDING FIRM ON THEIR BELIEF
THAT ISRAEL, THE VICTIM, IS EVIL
HERE, LED BY THE SQUAD LEADER,
CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, SHE
WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE THAT ISRAEL
ISN'T EVEN A COUNTRY.
JUST AN OCCUPIER OF STOLEN LAND.
APPARENTLY SHE WANTS THE
MILLIONS OF IN ISRAEL TO JUST
GET LOST AND HAND OVER THE KEYSG
DEMOCRACY TO THE TERRORISTS AND
HAMAS.
AOC'S FELLOW SQUAD MEMBERS, IN
THIS CASE, CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR,
WELL, SHE JUST ACCUSED ISRAEL
OF!
CLEANSING.
CONGRESSWOMAN TLAIB SAID
THAT HAS
CONTINUED TO BE ENABLED AND
SUPPORTED BY THIS
PRIME MINISTER.
>> Sean: SO FROM THE SQUAD, WE
SEE IT BEFORE, WE SEE AT NOW,
AND THAT IS, YEAH, VIRULENT
ANTI-SEMITISM.
REMEMBER WHAT I'VE BEEN TELLING
YOU, THE SQUAD RUNS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE NEW GREEN
DEAL SOCIALISM,
THAT IS THE SQUAD'S PLAN.
NANCY PELOSI, CHUCKIE SCHUMER,
JOE BIDEN FEAR THE SQUAD AND
WHEN THEY SAY JUMP, WELL, THEY
ARE JUST ASKING HOW HIGH.
GIVEN THIS KIND OF LOGIC,
RHETORIC, IS ANYONE REALLY
SURPRISED THAT AN ANTI-ISRAELI
PROTEST IN NEW YORK, WELL, THAT
ERUPTED IN VIOLENCE, AS THE
CROWD ATTACKED A PASSERBY,
LEAVING THIS MAN BLOODIED AND
BRUISED.
KEEP IN MIND, THE LEFT RARELY
HAS ANYTHING NEGATIVE TO SAY
ABOUT HAMAS.
THEY ARE A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION THAT OPPRESSES THE
PALESTINIAN PEOPLE, USES THEM AS
HUMAN SHIELDS.
THE OFTEN FIRE THEIR ROCKETS
FROM SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS.
THEY BOW IN THEIR OWN CHARTER TO
WIPE ISRAEL OFF THE FACE OF
THE PLANET AS PART OF THEIR
"STRUGGLE" AGAINST THE JEWS."
THANK GOD FOR THE IRON DOME,
WHICH YOU CAN SEE HERE IN
ACTION.
WE SHOWED YOU LAST NIGHT, THIS
TECHNOLOGY WAS DEVELOPED IN
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN OUR ALLIES,
ISRAEL, AND THE UNITED STATES,
IN A BETTER TIME AND A BETTER
PLACE.
IT SHOOTS ROCKETS RIGHT OUT OF
THE SKY, AND SO FAR, HAMAS HAS
LAUNCHED A WHOPPING 1,200 PLUS
PROJECTILES INTO ENGINE REAL.
MANY OF THEM AIMED AT HIGH
POPULATION AREAS.
WHY?
FOR MAXIMUM IMPACT AND MAXIMUM
DAMAGE AND DEATH AND INJURY
AGAINST INNOCENT CIVILIANS.
WITHOUT THE IRON DOME, THE HUMAN
COST WOULD BE UNIMAGINABLE.
AND BREAKING TONIGHT, AS WE
SPEAK, THE